the starks of winterfell traced their
descent to the first men in the age of
heroes
the family's founder was brandon the
builder who in the aftermath of the long
night helped establish the night's watch
legend has it he enlisted the aid of
giants and the powerful magic of the
children of the forest to raise the
mighty wall
which has protected the realm for
generations
he went on to build the ancestral seat
of winterfell and reigned as the first
king in the north
the starks take great pride in their
history and traditions
it is one of the few noble houses that
still keeps the old gods
a sacred weirwood tree looms large in
winterfell's godswood
its ancestral sword ice was forged in
ancient valeria it has been passed down
through the generations
house stark remains steadfast in its
support of the night's watch even as the
once illustrious order has fallen on
hard times
much like their sigil the grey direwolf
how stark is the stuff of legend in the
north and throughout the seven kingdoms
and their family words
winter is coming
serve as a reminder of their beginnings
in the wake of the long night
under importance of things to come
like the starks the blood of house
bolton runs back to the first men
singers call those times the age of
heroes
a mask for a savage world that bred
savage men
the lannisters swindled their enemies
the storm kings hammered them and the
starks cut off their heads
in such company as this
with the boltons really so
indelicate
unlike some other houses
my ancestors owned the bolton words
our blades are sharp
they pass down not a valyrian great
sword but a knife
honed and thin enough to fit between the
topmost layer of skin and the tissue
below
and peel
for as we all learned as children
a naked man has few secrets
a flayed man nun
in those dark days they say that some of
my more willful forbearers would even
wear their enemy's skins as cloaks
but no such tokens remain
if they ever existed
certainly not hanging in some secret
room in the dreadfort as old wives and
fools insist
[Music]
i suspect my house itself was
responsible for spreading such rumors in
the first place
few weapons are as effective as terror
and this was an age of war
house against house
brother against brother
the iron men were on the rise and never
far from our shores
we must have seemed ripe for the taking
too busy fighting each other to deal
with the raiders as they deserved
thus the starks took it upon themselves
to unify the north
under them
they drove the pirates out of white
knife and claimed the eastern coast and
married the marsh king's daughter for
the neck
a stark wrestled for bear island and won
or so they say
silly stories
blood and steel won the north
and the starks had the most of both
with most of the south in aegon's hands
the best chance to throw back the
conqueror now lay with the north
if we cared enough to try
unlike our southern rivals the stark
kings of winter didn't forge the north
into one kingdom for glory or gold there
is little of either here
but to survive alone in westeros the
north remembered when worse than dragons
lay waste to armies
thousands of years ago the sun set on
the realms of men and the long night
began
a new race emerged from the ice and snow
the white walkers they demanded no crown
offered no terms spared no life and the
dead marched with them with humanity
facing extinction a stark sought out the
children of the forest most ancient
beings in westeros and convinced them to
ally with the men they once fought
together the two races pushed the
walkers back into the land of always
winter and sealed it off from the seven
kingdoms with the wall
300 miles of ice stone and earth rising
nearly 700 feet tall
to guard it they established the night's
watch a brotherhood sworn to defend the
living from the dead whose vows are
raised both titles and crimes
after the long night the north tried to
forget it belonged to a continent
perhaps through pride perhaps through
sheer ignorance you never can tell with
the north
but as news of aegon's dragons spread
torrensta the king of winter
knew he couldn't forget westeros any
longer
and summoned his lords to winterfell
many fools shrugged off the threat
while the rest placed wages on how long
the south would take to burn
tauren silenced them with a command to
assemble their armies and descend from
the north in force
as the kings of the rock and the reach
burned on the field of fire the greatest
northern force since the long night
crossed the neck into the riverlands
but when king tauren arrived at the
trident he saw on the opposing riverbank
the combined strength of all aegon's
conquered kingdoms
a force larger than tauren's own by half
and with three dragons
that night king tauren called the
conference of all his lords and advisers
some wanted to fight and trust northern
valor to carry the day
and burn on the triton
the wisest of them wanted to withdraw to
mope kalin the fortress which had thrown
back every southern invasion
and burn there
one suicidal lord even wanted to ambush
aegon's camp in the dark and kill the
dragons as they slept or at the very
least their riders
it's hard to tell what would have been
his fate
burning
beheading
dismemberment
perhaps all three
my ancestors listened to their council
and in the morning crossed the trident
under a flag of pales then king tauren
of house stark laid his ancient crown at
aegon's feet and was named lord of
winterfell and warden of the north
and the king who knelt
he had no choice and thanks to him our
soldiers returned to their homes whole
and unharmed
the swords that aegon took from them
were not twisted burnt or mangled
yet
then came lord wendt's tourney at
harrenhal the largest ever in westeros
ironhorsed every man against me until
only prince rhaegar remained
we each set our feet in our saddles and
lowered our lances and charged
and i fell
muddy and bruised i then watched rhaegar
present lyanna stark with the victor's
crown of roses though she was betrothed
to robert baratheon and rhaegar himself
was married to elia martell
we all know what happened after
have i been a bit quicker with my lunch
if i'd chosen a faster horse
perhaps i could have spared the kingdom
from the destruction that came after
or if i thought to warn brandon stark
against his rashness he came to king's
landing himself demanding rhaegar return
his sister
poor fool
if he'd only known the depth of aries
madness he wouldn't have dared provoke
him
ares ordered brandon imprisoned and i
could do nothing but obey
when brandon's father lord rickardstark
came to king's landing to beg for his
son
aerys burned him alive
and i could do nothing but watch
i had sworn a vow to a mad king
and was honor bound to obey him even at
the cost of my soul
we urged heiress to pardon brandon stark
the boy had threatened prince rhaegar
but rhaegar had stolen the boy sister
and the boy was the eldest son of our
warden of the north
who's the greater fool a mad king or the
man who reasons with him ares saw knives
in every shadow
when you told him to treat the starks
with caution you made him afraid
and what he feared
he killed
i wouldn't have thought you of all
people would bother with recriminations
for brandon's death lord baelish
not after your shall we call it duel
with him
brandon was as arrogant as he was stupid
like his father lord stark who answered
aries summoned to the capital
they earned their fates
but the younger son ned what was his
crime that ares ordered his death as
well
unlike men families don't die when you
lop off their head
when did you know you'd lost lord varys
when robert baratheon killed prince
rhaegar on the trident wrong
you lost the war when you let ned stark
slip back into the north
neither the bloody gate of the vale or
what kalin in the north have ever fallen
they could have held out for years even
if you'd killed robert would you let him
slip through your fingers as well
i told the court that robert was hiding
in the stony sept but the hand of the
king wasted too much time searching the
city
something about the glory of single
combat
then ned stark's army arrived to save
the day
robert won
and my husband avenged his brother and
my love
but when he came home to me
he could not meet my eyes
i saw the reason
by his side
many men have bastards i know
and under the strain of war any man no
matter how honorable may forsake his
vows for a night of warmth that he may
never know again
but ned stark was not built like other
men
his northern honor would not let him
sequester his shame in some distant
holdfast
he brought this boy this
jon snow
home to raise with his trueborn children
my children
the starks are of the north and
like the snows of winter when they come
south
they melt away